et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
Franck Riester bonjour merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous charger des relations
avec le Parlement on est ensemble
pendant 20 minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse régionale
représentée par Fabrice don du groupe
Ebra bonjour Fabrice bonjour bonjour on
va évidemment parler du budget en tant
quelques instants mais d'abord la crise
des carburants Elizabeth borne a reconnu
hier que la situation s'était dégradée
ce weekend 30% des stations services
connaissent des difficultés est-ce
qu'Emmanuel Macron n'a pas parlé trop
vite en prévoyant en retour à la normale
dans le courant de cette semaine vous
avez un peu sous-estimé le climat social
non mais on doit rester concentré on va
rester concentré à la fois à inciter les
entreprises à dialoguer mais aussi à
respecter le dialogue social quand il y
a des accords majoritaires dans les
entreprises apprennent négociations il
faut que le travail reprenne et nous
prendrons nos responsabilités comme nous
le prenons nous l'apprenons depuis
maintenant quelques jours pour
réquisitionner quand c'est nécessaire
parce que nous devons faire en sorte que
cette situation cesse moi je pense à
toutes qui partout en France ont besoin
de prendre leur voiture pour aller
travailler pour aller emmener leurs
enfants à l'école pour vivre tout
simplement et qui sont contraints
bloqués qui sont inquiets aussi de
savoir est-ce qu'ils vont pouvoir avoir
du carburant pour continuer de vivre
normalement et pouvoir aller travailler
ou pour avoir s'occuper ces enfants et
donc je crois vraiment que là il faut
avancer prendre en compte les
négociations et penser aux français
surtout quand il y a eu des avancées
dans les négociations sociales alors
mais ce matin à l'instant d'ailleurs la
CGT annonce que la grève est reconduite
sur les cinq sites du groupe Total
est-ce qu'il faut procéder dès
maintenant avec une scission je vous ai
dit ce que j'en pensais et ce qu'on
pense la première ministre nous
prendrons nos responsabilités mais quand
le moment venu
Oriane nous interroge à l'instant sur
avez-vous sous-estimé auriez-vous
sous-estimé le climat social en France
est-ce que la situation est comparable
aux gilets jaunes
nous ne savons pas si sous-estimer la
difficulté de nos compatriotes dans
cette crise c'est pour ça qu'on a pris
d'abord des décisions très fortes en
matière de bouclier énergétique on est
un des premiers pays Européens à avoir
pris des décisions fortes pour protéger
nos compatriotes face à l'inflation dès
2021 aujourd'hui c'est 46 milliards
d'euros qui sont mobilisés dans le
budget 2023 46 milliards d'euros pour
protéger nos compatriotes en limitant à
15% l'augmentation de l'électricité et
du gaz nous avons pris conscience de ces
difficultés en dans le projet de loi de
finance rectificative augmentant les
retraites augmentant les salaires des
fonctionnaires en incitant les
entreprises quand elles le peuvent
d'augmenter les salaires en donnant des
outils pour ça regardez la prime Macron
défiscaliser des socialisés regardez les
dispositifs qui permettent de baisser le
coût pour l'entreprise et pour le
salarié des RT de prendre des RTT de
prendre des heures supplémentaires de
faire des heures supplémentaires
que vous considérez avoir anticipé la
situation contrairement à ce que ça
c'est pour les gilets jaunes oui on
pense qu'on a anticipé les difficultés
de nos compatriotes face à l'inflation
en mettant en place toute une boîte à
outils pour les entreprises pour
augmenter du pouvoir d'achat
complémentaire aux salariés en
indexant les pensions de retraite sur
l'évolution de l'inflation et en
augmentant les pensions de retraite en
faisant en sorte de d'augmenter les
toutes les prestations sociales nous
avons augmenté toutes les prestations
sociales de 4%. en augmentant l'indice
des fonctionnaires en augmentant les
fonctionnaires de 3,5% d'une façon
globale bref on est convaincu de la
difficulté de nos compatriotes et entre
le bouclier énergétique et toute la
politique était dans le projet de loi
pouvoir d'achat et le projet de loi de
finance rectificatif de donner une
bouffée d'oxygène à nos compatriotes en
termes de revalorisation soit des
retraites soit des pensions de
partenaires soit bien évidemment du
traitement des fonctionnaires soit bien
évidemment aussi des prestations
sociales et toute la boîte à outils dans
les entreprises pour négocier et pour
revaloriser les salaires pour revenir du
coup la grève des carburants comment
vous qualifier ce matin l'attitude de la
CGT des abats de bornières leur demande
d'arrêter de bloquer le pays ce matin il
reconduisent la grève comment vous
qualifiez ça mais nous pensons que il
faut effectivement débloquer le pays et
que la responsabilité des syndicats
apprennent négociation c'est de sortir
de la grève et de sortir de la grève en
pensant à nos compatriotes en pensant à
eux et il y a eu des revalorisations
mais en pensant aussi à tous celles et
ceux qui ne peuvent pas se passer de
carburant pour travailler ou pour vivre
un mot de la mobilisation on parle de
vie cher 30 à 140 000 selon les chiffres
personne mobilisé hier dans les rues
contre la vie chère comment jugez-vous
voulez-vous cette mobilisation syndicale
et puis autour quand même de votre
principal opposant Jean-Luc Mélenchon
c'était pas une mobilisation syndicale
c'est une mobilisation politique faible
faible mobilisation politique vous avez
entendu le sénateur Ferro et s'exprimer
tout à l'heure à ce titre je crois
vraiment que
pendant que nous essayons
quand on voit la faiblesse de la
mobilisation hier et quand on voit cette
volonté de créer du désordre de baptiser
les difficultés par
cette attitude souvent agressive de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon et en contrepartie
enfin en miroir la façon dont nous
essayons de régler les problèmes de nos
compatriotes je laisse les Français
jugent de quoi ça veut dire qu'il est
pas responsable pour vous Jean-Luc
Mélenchon
faut écouter je laisse à son agitation
pendant que encore une fois nous nous
concentrons sur le problème de nos
compatriotes tu sais moi les polémiques
des uns des autres j'essaie de les
mettre de côté une concentrer sur
l'essentiel comment on débloque le pays
comment revalorise les salaires comment
on fait en sorte que les Français
tiennent face à l'inflation je le
rappelle l'inflation la plus faible de
l'Union européenne on a 6 % d'inflation
en France quand on en a 10 en Allemagne
17 au Pays-Bas et nos compatriotes
voient bien que la façon dont on a
traité cette crise énergétique est on
traite cette crise énergétique par
rapport à nos voisins européens est bien
souvent reconnu par nos compatriotes on
va parler du budget évidemment puisque
les députés reprennent aujourd'hui
l'examen du budget ce sera cet
après-midi alors Elisabeth borne a dit
hier soir que le 49-3 ça ne serait pas
pour aujourd'hui c'est pour quand
on a enfin un débat qui est prévu
jusqu'à mercredi
donc nous aurons besoin à l'issue du
débat de voter le budget puisque on doit
donner à au pays un budget pour payer
les fonctionnaires pour permettre
justement la politique par exemple de
bouclier énergétique et donc nous
prenons nos responsabilités le moment
venu d'utiliser cet outil prévu par la
Constitution qui est pas un passage en
force mais qui nous permet de voter le
budget pourquoi je dis pas de passage en
France parce que un c'est prévu dans la
Constitution et deux on a laissé le
temps au débat ça fait maintenant
presque une semaine qu'on débat du
projet de loi de finance dans
l'hémicycle après un travail en
commission après les dialogues de Bercy
ou Gabriel Attal et Bruno Le Maire ont
reçu toutes les forces politiques pour
pouvoir discuter et changer du budget
vous irez jusqu'au bout donc mercredi le
49 3 mais pourquoi voulez-vous qu'on
n'aille pas jusqu'au bout du débat donc
mercredi
pour l'instant du sens même s'il y a eu
un certain nombre d'amendements qui
coûtent très cher à un moment on doit
veiller à la maîtrise des dépenses
pourquoi ne pas dire on l'utilisera
mercredi on va au bout des débats on
utilisera mercredi on va au bout du
débat et on l'utilisera le moment vu
marine le Penner disait sur BFM TV hier
midi que ce qu'il a choque ce n'est pas
que vous utilisez le 49-3 mais que vous
ne l'ayez pas fait dès le début pour le
coup elle dit que des mesures ont été
votées des mesures que vous allez rayer
dans trade plume je la cite c'est un
déni de volonté populaire qu'est-ce que
vous répondez à faire vous voyez bien le
paradoxe de tout ça c'est que si on
avait utilisé le 49-3 parce que les
oppositions depuis le début nous disent
quoi qu'il y a dans le texte de toute
façon on retraconte on nous aurait
critiqué en disant vous utilisez le 49-3
vous muselez le Parlement et vous le
laissez pas le temps au débat maintenant
on laisse le temps au débat parfois avec
un certain nombre de mesures qui sont
prises qui sont complètement
orthogonales à ce qu'on a toujours
défendu et surtout au cadre financier
que l'on veut pour notre pays pour
limiter les déficits déjà que ces 5%
c'est un engagement la mort de notre
part pour accompagner le pays dans la
transformation et pour protéger les
Français on peut pas faire n'importe
quoi en matière budgétaire et donc nous
prenons nos responsabilités
effectivement à l'issue du débat mais
vous voyez bien soit c'est trop tôt et
on nous dit vous muselez le Parlement
soit c'est à l'issue du débat et vous
dites on nous dit aussi on vous muselez
le Parlement c'est un déni de démocratie
quasiment d'après Madame Le Pen alors
même que le débat c'est le texte va être
enrichi des débats et que nous tiendrons
compte bien évidemment au moment
déposeront le texte du 49-3 des échanges
qui ont été ceux de dans l'hémicycle et
et je rappelle aussi que ce texte il va
être voté là par le 49-3 enfin il va
être validé par le 49-3 à l'issue du
débat et ensuite il va aller au Sénat et
le Sénat va faire son rôle aussi
utile d'amélioration du texte on va y
venir sur le fond mais est-ce que le
fait d'avoir attendu la fin des débats
c'était aussi une manière
[Musique]
quelque chose qui est inutile moi j'ai
été parlementaire je suis parlementaire
depuis 2007 je sais l'importance du
travail du député ou du sénateur il faut
pas le le balayer d'un revers de la main
donc oui c'est pas simplement pour
l'image de personnes d'un gouvernement
qui est ouverte c'est vrai que nous le
sommes c'est vrai que nous voulons une
méthode où on prend le temps du débat
d'écouter le temps du compromis mais on
est convaincu vraiment sincèrement de la
pertinence du travail parlementaire et
donc quand on peut avoir un travail
parlementaire de qualité on le permet en
revanche évidemment tout ce qui est
obstruction
parodie de débarras et bien on prend nos
responsabilités et à l'issue des débats
et bien on utilise si jamais il y avait
eu une une obstruction une parodie de
débat à ce moment-là on aurait pris nos
responsabilités on aurait mis fin à
débat mais ça a pas été le cas donc on
va jusqu'au bout du débat sur le fond du
texte parce que c'est important si le
texte passe par le 49-3 ça veut dire
qu'il sera votre main quels amendements
vous pensez garder on verra à l'issue du
débat pour l'instant on écoute on
regarde on voit ce qui est voté et on a
je voulais un cadre une boussole cette
boussole c'est pas d'augmentation de la
fiscalité
ni pour les entreprises ni pour les
particuliers voire même la baisse je
rappelle que dans ce budget il y a la
baisse de l'impôt de production pour les
entreprises pour permettre à nos
entreprises de rester compétitives et de
même d'améliorer leur compétitivité dans
la compétition mondiale pour plus
d'emplois et plus de croissance et on
baisse les impôts pour les particuliers
avec par exemple l'indexation du barème
de l'impôt sur le revenu et ce qui
touche directement celles et ceux qui
payent l'impôt sur le revenu et puis
deuxièmement c'est le la maîtrise des
dépenses publiques on veut maîtriser les
dépenses publiques et rester dans les 5%
de prévisions de déficit pour 2023
notamment l'amendement sur les super
dividendes qui a été voté à l'initiative
du MoDem qui est votre allié est-ce que
celui-là il sera gardé par le
gouvernement nous verrons le moment
contenu quand il sera le temps de
présenter le texte sur le budget au
moment du 49-3 mais vous voyez que c'est
typiquement un amendement qui tombe dans
ce que est notre
boussole notre ligne rouge depuis
longtemps qui est la baisse de la
fiscalité ou la stabilité de la
fiscalité et ça c'est une augmentation
de la fiscalité donc plutôt non c'est
une augmentation de la physique mais
est-ce que vous garderez quand même des
amendements de l'opposition lors de
votre majorité même sur lesquels vous
n'êtes pas d'accord ou est-ce que vous
reviendrez au taxi initial je vous le
dis on tiendra compte bien évidemment du
travail parlementaire c'est absolument
clé et absolument au coeur de ce qu'on
souhaite faire tenir compte bien
évidemment du travail du pardon et
Elisabeth burn a parlé hier dans son
interview sur TF1 d'un échange
aujourd'hui avec les présidents de
groupes parlementaires ça sera les
présidents de tous les groupes
parlementaires opposition comprise ou
uniquement les présidents de votre
majorité la première ministre encore
reçu les présidents
de tous les groupes pour la réforme des
retraites et l'on contacte en permanence
avec les différents groupes de la
majorité mais aussi de l'opposition ce
qu'il faut avoir en tête et que
téléspectateurs et en tête c'est que les
oppositions
on dit dès le départ qu'il ne voterait
pas le budget et on dit aussi que même
s'il y avait des amendements qu'il
défendaient qui serait voté il ne il ne
voterait pas le texte pour autant c'est
à dire ce qui s'est passé en commission
il y a eu des amendements de voter de
l'opposition ils ont continué de voter
contre le texte pourquoi parce que c'est
un peu un marqueur de l'appartenance de
la majorité de l'opposition dont acte
mais à partir du moment où même avec des
amendements votés le texte ne sera pas
voté par les oppositions on prendra nos
responsabilités on votera le 49-3 et on
aura un texte qui ne sera pas le texte à
l'origine avant le travail parlementaire
ça sera un truc modifié mais en
faisant un certain nombre de choix qui
dépendront notamment de nos deux fils
rouges de nos deux boussoles fiscalité
baisse ou stabilité de l'impôt et les
taxes et de la maîtrise de la dépense
publique vous le dites c'est un marqueur
le budget est-ce que c'est d'autant plus
problématique que le modèle aille contre
la ligne du gouvernement sur certains
amendements quand on sait à quel point
c'est un marqueur politique non mais il
y a des dégâts il y a de la diversité
dans notre majorité tant mieux je veux
dire faut que la majorité vive et c'est
très bien si elle ne vit pas on dit
qu'on est des playmobils
l'association
d'opposition de dire ah ouais les
députés de la majorité ce sont des
Playmobil bah là ce sont pas des clubs
non mais exactement mais oui il y a la
diversité dans la majorité les sons
vivent la diversité en même temps
gardons bien en tête ce que sont nos
priorités les grands axes de ce qu'a
voulu le président de la République
quand il s'est présenté devant les
Français et en même temps tout le nom de
compte de cette vitalité de la majorité
et tenant compte de les apports aussi
parce qu'encore une fois on n'est pas
dans un regard manichéen sectaire on est
dans un regard qui prend en compte
l'amélioration du texte par les
oppositions et par la majorité en
position qui vont sans doute déposer des
motions de censure en tout cas c'est ce
qu'elles ont annoncé vous pensez
qu'elles peuvent passer
à priori non je vois pas comment des
oppositions qui n'ont rien à voir
s'unirai pour proposer de faire tomber
le gouvernement mais on verra bien le
gouvernement prend un risque d'ailleurs
parce que on présente le 49-3 comme un
passage en force facile pour le
gouvernement bah non c'est pas si facile
il se met aussi en risque il se met en
risque d'être
battue par une motion de censure et donc
que le gouvernement tombe bon bah on
prend nos responsabilités et on verra
bien à l'instant T d'après les
déclarations des uns et des autres la
motion de censure ne serait pas votée
mais vous savez en démocratie faut
respecter le vote une fois le texte
adopté à l'Assemblée on verra comment il
arrivera au Sénat qu'est-ce que vous
attendez des sénateurs sur ce texte
qu'ils apportent leur regard au texte
qu'il l'améliore qu'il fasse des
propositions et ensuite le texte
reviendra à l'Assemblée dans le cadre de
ce qu'on appelle la navette sur quel
point vous pensez que le travail va être
plus facile entre le gouvernement et la
majorité sénatoriale de la droite et du
centre mais l'améliore à la fois
techniquement prénom nous apporte un
regard qui est celui de regarder
sénateur notamment sur les collectivités
territoriales
[Musique]
qui protègent les finances des
collectivités dans le texte on a déjà
dans le texte on a dans le texte et la
première année c'est beaucoup engagée
sur le sujet
pour protéger les collectivités
territoriales je rappelle qu'il y a un
bouclier tarifaire les fameux 15%
d'augmentation d'électricité 15%
d'augmentation du gaz qui s'applique aux
particuliers mais qui s'appelait aussi
aux petites entreprises de moins de 10
salariés et aux petites communes de
moins de 10 à Jean et donc ça représente
presque 30 000 communes qui sont d'ores
et déjà protégés par
une extension à toutes les collectivités
pour vous il faut dire oui les autres
ont un dispositif qui permet de d'ores
et déjà cette voter dans le projet de
loi de finance rectificatif 2022 et il y
a des dispositions dans le budget 2023
pour protéger celles et ceux qui sont
particulièrement impactés par cette
augmentation du coût de l'énergie et
donc regarderons avec les associations
d'élus à travers le débat parlementaire
s'il faut aller encore plus loin de ce
qu'on a mis sur la table qui est
important je pense par exemple à se fond
vert d'un milliard et demi d'euros je
pense à cette DGF qui est augmentée
c'est historique pour les collectivités
territoriales et on prendra le temps à
nouveau de l'écoute du débat pour
essayer de répondre le mieux possible
aux problématiques de collectivités
territoriales à commencer par les
communes parce que ce sont souvent ces
communes de de plus de 5 ou 10 000
habitants qui sont particulièrement
impactés aujourd'hui une dernière
question sur ces collectivités et ce
budget il y a notamment la suppression
de la CV de la l'utilisation sur la
valeur ajoutée des entreprises qui est
prévu à horizon 2 ans dans ce budget
Gérard Larcher dit qu'il faudrait
décaler d'un an la suppression de ça
est-ce que ça ça fait partie des
compromis que vous pourriez accepter non
pourquoi parce que c'est le cœur de
notre stratégie fiscale et économique la
compétitivité des entreprises vous savez
on est dans un combat mondial la France
est pas seul elle est dans un monde qui
est compétitif et j'ai été ministre du
Commerce extérieur de l'attractivité et
je sais combien en quelques années grâce
à la politique fiscale et économique du
gouvernement
est des gouvernements qui sont succédés
et de la présidence d'Emmanuel Macron on
a amélioré notre attractivité notre
compétitivité ce qui a nous permet
d'avoir la croissance la plus forte de
la zone euro ce qui nous permet d'avoir
baissé notre chômage d'une façon
historique n'oublions pas que nous avons
besoin d'accompagner les entreprises
dans la compétition mondiale la
suppression de la CVAE en deux ans c'est
pas horizon 2 ans c'est dès cette année
la moitié et ensuite en 2024 pour
continuer de baisser les impôts qui
touchent les investissements des
entreprises dans les territoires et nous
proposons pour bien sûr assurer le
financement des collectivités
territoriales puisque cette CVAE finance
les collectivités territoriales un
dispositif autour de la TVA très
dynamique et avec un dispositif qui est
en cours encore en cours de de
finalisation un dispositif qui permettra
de faire un lien entre le territoire et
donc l'installation des entreprises et
le rendement de la fiscalité néanmoins
la taxe foncière explose pour les
propriétaires en France la fiscalité
n'est pas à la baisse partout bien
écoutez il y a effectivement une
revalorisation des balles locatifs qui
est prévue par la loi charges aux
collectivités locales qui le peuvent ou
qu'ils le souhaitent de baisser le taux
de cette taxe pour qu'il n'y ait pas
d'impact sur les
concitoyens sur les Français
nous avons une loi qui prévoit en
fonction de l'évolution de l'inflation
une augmentation des bases locatives
charges encore une fois aux
collectivités de prendre leur décision
politique de maintenir les taux de les
baisser ou de les augmenter en fonction
de leurs problématiques de financement
un mot sur un autre texte c'est la
réforme des retraites est-ce qu'un
amendement au budget de la Sécurité
sociale est définitivement exclue
écoutez nous vous avons fait le choix du
dialogue de la concertation certains
nous disent ils vont passer en force
comme d'habitude si je puis dire pas le
cas
pour les retraites comme d'habitude
contrairement à ce qui est dit nous
prenons le temps de la concertation du
dialogue et de l'ouverture
Isabelle bande je le disais tout à
l'heure avec Olivier du SOP et moi-même
a reçu les différents groupes des partis
politiques représentées à l'Assemblée
nationale au Sénat au lieu du choc
rencontre les organisations syndicales
et tout un planning de un planning de
travail est prévu jusqu'à la fin de
l'année pour tenir compte des remarques
des avis et des propositions ensuite la
première ministre fera un bilan de c'est
concertations à la fin de l'année un
texte sera proposé en début d'année
prochaine ça premier texte proposé au
Parlement janvier alors
vraisemblablement le premier texte
présenté au Conseil des ministres oui et
votez avant la fin de l'hiver c'est
clair c'est ambitieux et en même temps
on prend le temps de la discussion et la
concertation tout à l'heure je parlais
de mobilisation politique maintenant on
parle de la mobilisation syndicale elle
est demain celle-là est-ce que elle peut
impacter sur votre façon d'opérer pour
la réforme des retraites non notre façon
pourquoi on supprimerait la concertation
le dialogue s'il y a des manifestations
au contraire on tirage ou des blocages
ou des blocages on va continuer cette
politique qui vise à la fois de tenir
les engagements qui a pris le président
de la République de s'assurer de la
pérennité du système de retraite de
continuer à améliorer système de
retraite pour conforter les pensions de
retraite pour que cette réforme ce
système de retraite soit plus juste et
donc de rallonger l'âge de départ en
retraite pour travailler jusqu'à
65 ans et notre objectif
d'ici à 2031 et puis en même temps de
prendre le temps de la concertation et
du dialogue pour améliorer le texte sur
par exemple le cumul retraite et emplois
pour prendre en compte le travail des
seniors pour prendre en compte l'égalité
femme pour prendre en compte les
retraites minimum vous voyez notre
proposition qui est de dire pour une
carrière complète il faut un minimum de
retraite de 1100 euros donc de
revaloriser les pensions de retraite
c'est ça notre politique assurer la
pérennité du financement de la retraite
et améliorer le système des retraites un
dernier mot sur un dernier texte c'est
là qui examine cette semaine une
proposition de loi pour
constitutionnaliser l'IVG c'est porté
par une sénatrice écologiste le texte
sera sûrement rejeté en séance puisqu'il
a été rejeté en commission est-ce que le
gouvernement va s'en emparer vous savez
que nous souhaitons protéger ce droit
important il y a eu des propositions de
loi il y a des propositions de loi à la
fois au Sénat et à l'Assemblée nationale
et et on verra comment ville débat mais
vous gardez la proposition de il y aura
pas de projet de loi là-dessus on verra
les sons les sénateurs les députés
parler de ces questions et trouvons la
meilleure façon pour s'assurer que ce
droit important soit sanctuarisé dans
notre pays et à l'Assemblée le
gouvernement prendra ses responsabilités
comme toujours nous voulons nous
protéger ce droit si important qu'est le
droit à l'IVG merci merci à vous merci
beaucoup
d'avoir l'air de
[Musique]